the team gets carlos rodon back today
boy he's been good this year 11-5 got a
2-4-1 e-r-a he's got a whip under one at
.98 shift on in the infield for
schwarber the lefty
a lot of pop in that bat here's the 2-2
to schwarber called strike three
inside slider painted the corner tanner
howell gets the call in the opener owen
three on the year for the right-hander a
3-2-6 e-r-a coming off a five-shutout
inning start against the indians
coming along now
jose abreu
leading the league in rbis actually it's
tied with salvi perez now in kansas city
with a 104 there three
in front of devers 28 home runs hitting
a 265
last year as american league most
valuable player
and the pitch hey he tried to check on a
slider away and he did not strike three
he just nodded his head in agreement
with the first base umpire molino who
made the call
first baseman bobby dalbeck will hit
with two out in the inning and no one on
2-2 swung on fouled into the mitt
another strikeout for carlos rodon on a
mile an hour fastball his second of the
night
see you later bobby dulbeck so the white
sox will hit in the bottom of the second
still no score
danny santana
will bat with a man on
vasquez the runner at first here's the
one-two pitch called strike three got
him on a slider
carlos rodon just aced danny santana and
there's one away so bring up jose
iglesias he's the nine-hitter and had
been playing a lot of shortstop just
picked up by the red sox four games ago
he was released by the angels earlier
this month
white sox in their black tops
white pants the black pinstripes
red sox in their traveling grays runner
at third one away 3-2 count on the
nine-hitter iglesias sling to miss rodon
gets him with a fastball works not done
though
he'll face [ __ ] hernandez
vazquez away from third here's the o2 to
hernandez swing and a miss
rodon gets him with 98 at the top of the
zone and will strut off the field
here at guaranteed rate
he keeps the red sox off the board and
that man comes to the plate it's jose
abreu
he is tied for first
and total runs batted in this season
infield back on the white sox first
baseman first and second they take their
leads here's the o2 pitch pounded in the
left danny santana turns around and it's
gone
jose o'brien with an 0-2 three-run shot
and the white sox lead at three to
nothing
this place
is lit
that's what the doctor ordered
hunter renfro was a fly out
in the first
there's a 3-2 swinging miss
got renfro on a fastball away
that is the sixth strikeout for carlos
rodon and this will bring up a dangerous
man in rafael devers
three-nothing white sox
rodon's 3-2 pitch to devils is a swing
and a miss on a slider
devers chucks the bat launches the
helmet
but he's punch out victim number seven
of carlos rodon
we head to the bottom of the fourth so
sheets is a board and here comes leori
garcia
3-1
in the air behind short santana charges
in and bogarts jumps up to make the
catch
for out number one
danny santana took his eye off of bogey
for that split second bogey had he was
waving him the whole time i got it i got
it runners on the corners now and two
away for the leadoff man luis robert
sheets the runner at third
hernandez at first here's the 0-1 ground
ball through the right side and the
white sox lead it four to nothing on an
rbi single from luis robert and you got
the bases loaded
who's already got a three-run homer in
this game we'll say abray get the
feeling the game is on the line right
here and right now lefty throws a bray
who grounds it to the left side the
shortstop bogart's has it'll go the long
way to first and it is dug out by
dolbeck at first on a low throw to end
the inning and stem the tide an unearned
run the white sox leave them loaded in
the fourth
in the end good job by hernandez
four-nothing white side strikeout
swinging against a fastball from rodon
the first time for dalbeck
rodon's 1-0 and dalbeck crushes this one
oh he smoked that one and the red sox
are on the board
home run number 21 for bobby dulbeck
boy when he gets a pitch he does not
miss us and this is a high fastball not
his best fastball
but this ball is up out of the zone it's
almost a ball and he loses it time run
at the plate endeavors has been quite
dangerous
see if they've got it set here pitch
ground ball up the middle garcia ranges
to his left makes the play throws out
rafael devers job done by aaron bummer
great job coming out of the pen and
getting one of the most dangerous red
sox hitters in the lineup tonight four
to one white sox lead here's christian
vasquez christian is one for two with
the base head dull back at third with
nobody out anfield way back two and one
to vasquez here's the pitch swinging a
ground ball to the right side that will
get the run in dulbeck comes home to
score throw to first in time
but in the end a productive out for
vasquez and it's four to two
verdugo this season playing in his
130th game 289
with 12 homers and 51 driven in he's had
some real heroics lately
here's the 1-1 swing of line drive into
center field they will get the run home
santana rounds third he scores easily
the pinch hitter verdugo delivers and
it's a one run game on the south side
verdugo rocking the baby at first it's
four to three
now the bases are loaded for a brayu
taylor is ready with the bases loaded
here it is swinging a miss he got him on
an outside slider they leave him loaded
they've left 11. and the base is loaded
twice
we go to the ninth inning the red sox
trail four to three and liam hendricks
league leader would says will be coming
on
to try to nail this down for chicago
danny santana they hit her he's one for
three
pulled on the ground hernandez leaves
his feet
and they get the first out nice play by
hernandez diving
and here is travis shaw
3-2 with two outs a pitch
it will be robert and center
white sox take the opener
you